Hey guys, welcome to my channel. Thank
you guys for watching on another
episode. What we're working on today,
it's going to be a 2012 Hyundai Sonata.
So, what we're doing here, we're using
the Xorse cutting machine, going to the
Hyundai section and actually pulling up
the key. This one has like kind of a
special key that you have to pull up the
information to cut it. It's like the
inner type key that um Hyundai has,
Toyota has. So you'll see the type of
key that I'm talking about. So if you
can see there, generation, we're going
by the year. Then it tells you on what
uh what line to put it on. This is going
to be in the number one line. So if you
can see there, um that's the A section,
but if you flip it over, it's going to
be the B section. And it tells you on
your screen which one it wants. So if
you can see that type of key, it's going
to go ahead and uh measure it out and
trace it. and then get the actual key
cut. And then I'll start cutting the
actual key once I put a blade in there.
So that's my new blade. This is the new
uh blade number 77 for a flip key. So
here we're going to go ahead and connect
to the OBD2.
And in this case, we're just actually
programming a remote, which is going to
be OBD2 because these Hyundai, most of
them don't have any chips. So you don't
need to program anything. You just cut a
key and put a you you know, put a shell
and then turn the turn the ignition and
it'll turn it on because it doesn't need
a transponder ID. So, here we're just
going to program the remote. I like to
turn off the radio, the AC just to not
uh drain the battery because once your
battery is drained, it starts giving you
problems.
So, here we have the ignition on and
we're going to do an auto VIN.
Now, these Xorse keys have been
generated for this Hyundai, for this
Hyundai uh Sonata specifically, so they
will work only with this vehicle.
Now, you do have to have that hot spot
on and have some signal there. If you
can see, the VIN number did pop up. So,
it did extract the data. And now we're
going to go ahead and go to
Well,
here we're going to check on the tag. If
it was made in the USA, Europe, or
anywhere else here, it's going to be the
USA. It's going to be a blade key.
Then we're going to go to control unit
and then go ahead and hit remote learn
remote control learning.
And then once it enters into the system,
it's going to give you basic
instructions of what to do.
So it's telling you turn the ignition on
and off. So we're going to turn it off
and then take out the key. and then go
ahead and activate the programming mode
and hit the lock. And if you can see
there, programming has been successful.
Here we're doing two keys for the
customer. So that's a second remote that
has been successful.
And then from there, we start testing
the remotes out. See if they're fully
functioning. And if you could see there,
they are working properly. And we have a
complete key. Once we go ahead and mount
the blade and put the logo on there and
we have two successful keys that we've
sold. Thank you guys so much. If you
guys have any questions, please leave a
comment below and I'll go ahead and get
back to you as soon as I can. Have a
good one.